Here's the last compound inequality we'll look at. Notice I have two inequity
signs, and an expression with a variable in the middle. So you might be
wondering, is this an AND inequality, or an OR inequality. To think about it,
let's try splitting it up. Here's one inequality, so I'm going to write the one
here. And here's the second inequality. We want this amount to be greater than
negative 2 and we want this amount to be less than 4. So this is an AND
inequality. We know how to solve an AND inequality, and we could solve each of
these separately, but I'm going to show you something different. We're going to
solve this inequality by working with each part of the inequality. All three of
them. First I'm going to clear the fraction by multiplying every part by 5. 5
times negative 2 is negative 10. Here, I'm going to put the 5 over 1, then I'm
going to reduce the common factors in the numerator and the denominator. So
these 5's reduce to 1. Now that you have an idea of how to perform the
operations to every part, I want you to finish this one out. Write your answer
in interval notation in this box. Remember to use parentheses or brackets and a
comma to separate the numbers from the interval. Good luck.